thanks for tuning in to another episode
of have to be talked this episode is the
bitching files the bitching sessions and
it is brought to you by my fantastic
sponsor el cajon harley located in
southern california the number one
Harley dealer to me absolutely you know
you got to get a motorcycle man what are
you doing get a bike man go to El Cajon
talk to Greg and say del Rey sent me
they got fantastic motor closer an
excellent service department and they
also are going to have the brand new
Harley Davidsons on sep tember I think
its third and fourth they're gonna have
the brand new fleet you can go down
there ride them I'm going to be down
there I got to ride the brand new motor
the motor came out today go check it out
at El Cajon Harley what are you doing
just get a t-shirt there prove to them
that uh you know their sponsorship is
working do it get your bike yeah you see
that spicy the new motor yeah uh one
holy crap to wait and see like I don't
is this new Harley is this like Harley's
good everything they make is good like
it's rough around the edges s what we
want it to be or is this like hey this
is a Mazda making a rotary engine in the
eighth he's like look at this dump new
engine yeah don't buy this engine I'm a
little apprehensive well everybody's
always I don't buy the first year yeah
I've been hearing that my entire life
they've been working on this for what 10
yeah that you've heard about it coming
yeah well they secretly were working on
new motor and of course it's no it's no
mystery that Indian is uh they're
actually [ __ ] making a charge and
also ducati has been smoking it the last
five years ducati and beamers always
killing it with their GS and stuff so
Harley I think finally had to you know
yeah you know when you're the top guy
you get a little lazy and then here
comes these other companies but I've
wrote all the bikes for years now I've
owned beamers have owned Ducatis I've
owned
Harley's and and I like them all but to
me it always feels and I'm not some guy
american-made man who you know to me
it's not that but the other bikes are
fantastic but they're little boring
after a while they don't have soul
there's something about the Harley you
can constantly customize it all the
other companies yeah the other companies
you buy it it's done off the [ __ ]
showroom maybe some slip on exhaust
that's it and and then you just kind of
get bored after a while cuz your bike
looks like everybody else's with Harley
can really make it your own but what
Holly did was they and they were
secretly working on this motor and this
motor first of all they upgraded the
twin cam motor which is what i have in
my bike about two years ago ok and i was
like holy [ __ ] this bike as night and
day from three years ago ok so they've
been actually doing upgrades but in the
indian world it was all about numbers
like our bike comes with a 111 yeah but
I wrote it and it was a great bike but
gone 11 look at the numbers not what you
feel under your butt look at yours a
spreadsheet yeah red sheet home it
didn't feel like a 111 to me my bike
isn't 103 cubic inch and when I [ __ ]
gas it on the freeway this thing's
moving they say the new motor is will
put you three bike lengths ahead of the
other one I can't even imagine what that
torque must be like cuz Harley's all
about torque yeah low end just like you
used to do a wheelie to start like
there's no way to launch without getting
the front off the ground I can't wait to
check it out it's got two plugs per head
so that they did that back on their race
bike in the late 70s a dual spark plug
per head it's four valves kind of a
little Honda
but smooth as [ __ ] and then here's the
big thing that blew me back if anybody
rides Harley's or if you don't you're
like who cares you're bored right now
but if you ride Harley's they make two
motives okay one is called the
counterbalance where the faster you go
the more vibration to get and that's
old-school Harley for the old-school
people which I don't know anybody that's
like we're the ladies I don't know
anything about but I don't know anybody
that's like I need my bike to vibrate
the [ __ ] out of it and then they make
the rubber mounted which is in all the
touring ones men in the motor is in
rubber mounts and the faster you go the
smoother it goes the rubber mats soak up
the vibration and it works like crazy
but with the counterbalance motor the
counter balance is back go back and
forth when you're at a stoplight so the
motor just sit still where the rubber
mounted it's sitting on it's sitting in
rubber swords doing this so people
always get like what's with the motor so
the new one they did counter balance and
rubber mounted which means it's got to
be so [ __ ] smooth yeah and then they
redid the suspension on the baggers
front and back I'm dying to see that and
I'm dying to ride this motor now like I
said it will get out of this topic s it
seems I cover this people always say
don't buy the first year it comes with I
think it's a three year warranty
unlimited miles yeah and if it just
breaks down a bunch lemon ball see you
later right yeah I mean like who cares
and of course they will next year ago
well we this one we changed the crank
and stuff or whatever I get it they
always want to keep selling yeah I
always want to keep selling yeah that's
every year and no you shouldn't buy the
first year you shouldn't buy the second
near you shouldn't buy the third year
you should buy no year you should you
should never we should all just own hot
black Honda Civics yeah like we're
talking about shoulds yeah like of
course not no one should own the iphone
6s plus of course not yeah but that's
not what we're talking about here we
should all take the bus and we should
all eat whole-grain natural organic
foods that we grow ourselves
anything else other than that of course
we shouldn't yeah I mean like I wasn't
ever gonna I wasn't gonna buy another
harley touring bike yeah i was riding
beamers GS is I'm like fun it's great i
love a man riding [ __ ] rain snow
whatever dirt and then when they can of
the the all the upgraded [ __ ] two years
ago 2014 my buddy just hay ride the bike
and [ __ ] I wrote it I was like I can't
even believe the night nine-day
difference from last year yeah today you
know so this one's got to be even more
crazier and if I if I get on and like it
I'll probably on it oh yeah you know
when back when did it go on sale because
there's they go out to dealers for demos
and September's sale is it like marchers
no I think it's September 17 they're
gonna go yeah so the third and fourth it
used to be when i worked at Harley as
soon as you saw them yeah and i don't
know why they don't do this anymore
because it's genius they were in the
stores on the friday wow it just moved
gases into the store right now it's like
sitting wait you know maybe they're
bigger now I know cuz i do remember
before I growing up like one of my good
friends he had a bunch of old cars
mustangs and camaros into bikes too and
like when we would go to do like bike
stuff with him I feel like it was a
drive yeah now I feel like you see like
you'll be in the nice part of town and
there's a Harley dealership you know
yeah like LOL said you yeah Harley's are
every should be like go go past the meth
house now see my mother my mother's
brother's a metal roofing factory hit
bull dog shelter yeah take a right at
the shooting range yeah and then you're
fine you're fine Todd I'll get in Todd's
truck and he'll drive your four miles
back to the minute what that's
exaggeration but I feel like I tell you
I tell you what you do is you buy a
[ __ ] 2016 right now you're a dirt
cheap because that bike mine's got
20,000 miles on it right now and put a
nickel in to it and it's [ __ ]
phenomenal ok guys bye Dean's bike so he
can go buy it I that's all you're doing
yeah it's a great bike no no I'm saying
I would buy a 16 in one minute if you
got like [ __ ] three four thousand
dollars off right the bike will last you
a lifetime I'm not gonna sell mine I
love the color they don't make that
color you know well they will I have
what mine was like a hundred that was it
i wish they made that color I feel like
doesn't harley harley is a different
type of manufacturer but i think the
comparison works harley to me is the
motorcycle equivalent of Porsche yeah
well like Porsche will do anything for
you yeah but come in a bike oh no we
don't have that option I mean we do they
don't have nominees it's weird with
paints they're just like that's it man
yeah it's really which is cool because
then you know you go oh I remember that
that was 14 they made a hundred you know
what I mean all that limited paints are
putting women because Porsche will do
that but then they'll do paint a sample
you'll come in with whatever you want to
call it like you know you to torch or we
don't do this Evan T to torch anymore
what about this yeah like sure and
they'll call that sample read sample
1600 torch to write they don't give it a
name it's just paint to say yeah yeah
yeah whatever I'm pretty interested to
see where I'm the other than that not
much new in the Harley world they're all
the other than the touring bikes the
other bikes are the same yeah they kept
all of that same that's how r lee is
next year don't move the motor into the
other platforms you know they'll see how
it goes down but what's a big thing when
you have fans that love that still you
know swear by a counterbalance bike yeah
getting them something new and no longer
offering that like 10 years from now
will they not even have one or we'll
just be called like the heritage or
something you know like yeah just to
please the old-timers it's it's a
difficult business win and I think like
Nintendo and the video game world does
is to and so much of your IP is tied to
your heritage in your history like
mustangs and camaros and you want to do
something new and keep up but same time
you know you are what you are yep so
well that's what they say Harley's a big
problem is they've been dealing with
young kids oh my god why would I buy a
Harley yeah that's like I don't know
they're going off the heritage of the
guys like I'm 50 right I'm probably
they're probably the last guys are
around 40 that really understand like I
gotta have a Harley you know and the
other people young people are like I
like the Ducati scrambler yeah but you
know you find out right away you know
you get those other bikes and and then
you're riding around and no one's going
a sweet bike or whatever and then I'll
sitting there like I want a horror we
don't know when was the last great like
motorcycle movie oh yeah it's a good we
need to go like fashion the Furious
whether you like those cars are not like
they have a lot of you know Japanese two
hours and that but they also like Vin
Diesel's in what a 67 charger yep you
know like it's kind of like runs the
gamut of cars trying to think of like
the last whether it's a ninja or
whatever but like a movie that
celebrated bikes well I did that hell
ride movie you know and I was really
open that that was gonna be more
concentrated on the bikes yeah and you
know riding and everything and of course
it just kind of turned out different
just went to TV right like they never
had the movie I know not all right no
notnot hell ride but the idea of
motorcycle culture oh yeah well you know
what I the [ __ ] sons anarchy really
bumped Harley big-time bumped him up
which is what makes me pretty surprised
that they've been hurting lately because
so many people went out and bought
[ __ ] knows those Harley Dinah's that
you know the same crew rides you know
and even Harley it's so funny when when
when sons of anarchy first came out all
I said we don't want nothing to deal
with it huh they had to buy their own
bikes and it came to the shop when I was
working there and I said I sold him two
bikes I remember they had like no money
you know like we got about seven grand
per bike I'm Mike well he's that ain't
gonna happen
and they go what if we just have like
two Harleys in the back we have like
hondas and [ __ ] I go your show or
immediately suck these are like not the
creators not the first year what does it
just yeah just money people yet bunch of
money people they know what what's the
difference like a well Amelia's show
will not be real no no my show is called
Ferrari club Dean you have one Ferrari
and every us in the back is in a Prius
will anyone notice that it's in a second
thing right away the bike first the
first people to watch the show are going
to be the bikers and then it spills into
other people if you got the bike season
to go that's bunk right out of the gate
no one's gonna now you got no views
close-up he's clearly getting on a
Harley they're like on the wide shot
it's like second ninja totally like when
i get hell ride they didn't have any
money for bikes so that was one of the
things if you had a bite oh sure you got
to audition and then they paid you 150 a
day rental for your bike which is cool
but you know in the meantime there's
there was no um there's no uniform to
the gangs bikes right in our gang we had
the gang the what were we called the
[ __ ] I can't even remember what we're
called now so long you're a pickup game
yeah you know anyway though you know one
guy had this bike the other guy had a
bike this guy you know I just kind of
looked funny but you know it looked it
kind of matched it because it was uh it
was kind of hokey sure you know which
made it good yeah yeah but anyway so
yeah there you go Harley's new motor I
think the last great bike movie we all
know as cool as ice no sighs what was
that vanilla ice Oh trying to do purple
rain oh that's [ __ ] hilarious there
was another one that ice cube did that
one was called like uh there aren't two
there was two like that's about the same
time in late 90s was torque that's it
Biker Boyz why I think it will get up
real quick see which one ice cube was it
i think the last cool bike movie was
that movie at Tupac was in where he
wrote a bike in it what was it Janet
Jackson love story oh no I de justice of
them two possible by
get it I was like yeah it's funny I
wanted to I tried to create this movie
for about TT was in torque torque yeah
about two years and when I was doing a
the film with cube I pitched him an idea
and loaned him the book but it's a book
about the first black motorcycle club
and it's it would be an incredible
awesome whoa [ __ ] is going on wow that
was pretty huge shutting you down he's
helping the movie I'll [ __ ] Dean
remember shutting all right but there's
a acrobat of Oakland and are we still
good we're not recording we're still
streaming oh wow special for the live
show oh [ __ ] uh-huh anyway oh so there's
a club in Oakland and east bay dragons
this is the first black bike game yeah
club well I think there was another one
in LA before which is the one down here
free what they're called but East Bay
dragons was Oakland and it's a couple
brothers started it and it's it's an
incredible book if you can read it I
read the book and I was like this would
be a great film yeah basically you know
it was back back in you know the days of
Oakland when they work they had no money
and they wanted to have a car club but
cars cost too much and you could get
bikes for like back then a hundred bucks
and they got bikes and they started a
club and and they're still around to
this day that's awesome and it's an
amazing story man they learned to ride
out at the oakland airport and the
fields and I could just see that vision
the whole film how cool it is to see
these guys man I mean it's cool to see
you know different styles of people
riding you know now all different kinds
of clubs and everything so it was it was
a great book and I gave it to cube he
was he was way into it and stuff too but
the two dudes that wrote the book or
just kind of crazy gallery we need like
10 million
I was like yeah we're making something
that five people want to see hahaha but
it was really uh there would have been a
great film and I read recently that
somebody else is trying to get it made
but can't get it over to Terrence Howard
or something right like someone actually
I talk to you about reduction right
after hustle and flow I saw Terrance
Howard and I love that so good if you
haven't seen it get movies underrated
right holy underrated man I think
Terrence Howard is so great he's smoked
in that movie but I saw him at a sushi
restaurant one night and I said a man I
don't want to bug you but uh I've got
this great idea he gave me his home
phone hahaha and I texted him a few
times and then of course did a like
Terrence Howard was like that sounds
great so I was thinking Terrence Howard
ice cube play the two brothers yeah and
cuz the brothers battle later on over
should they sell drugs instead of in the
book it's [ __ ] great ins when crack
hits in the idea and you see the ground
zero of crack the whole story's
phenomenal and then I was gonna have
Mike beach as the third guy in it also
and then I'm in there too you know I
woke up I was gonna play a cop I mean
yeah you give me the cup but like now
you're pitching it's got to be a Kevin
Hart yeah Terrence Howard maybe Jay
Farah I don't know like I gotta get
Kevin Hart can the rock put an afro on
what else who else can we get in this
thing speaking of that Jerry for our
tweeted today which should should I
start should I start the night of or
strange things not of yeah why God I'm a
John Turturro guy it's so good John
Tudor is a master man if you're gonna
start one yeah now only seven of the
eight night elves are available so do
stranger things you'll tear through it
in half a day 9 of is better it's just
but I'd rather watch bet it's a very
different very different and then I want
to see the gate down cuz i really really
i was reading about how to get down was
like [ __ ] it got made and then I was
like you know they were there like three
different [ __ ] rewrites and all this
problems and stuff and now
it's out and i hear it's great but i
love that early early hip-hop New York
and all that you know sir and I'm not
the flavor of the clothing yeah and the
mirror the glass is the shoes the
sneaker game the sweat see all that and
up in the blasters ghetto blasters it's
like you know do the right thing or you
know so I don't have you seen the good
day I haven't I've read about it and
apparently it's like really high highs
and really low lows really some stuff
works incredible and stuff some stuff
you're like are these actors like what
happened like it seems just kind of fall
apart and i should say the night of is
great the night of to me is like when
you go home and your mom put your old
Star Wars blanket on your bed for you or
like that and you're like oh cool this
is cool and it's cool and it's cool but
it's like scratching that itch yeah the
night of I feel like just I watched last
sunday's and i SAT there and I just
watched the whole credits at the end of
episode not intentionally but just
because I was just like right [ __ ] you
mean strange strange things strange
things it's like a Star Wars thing is
your star wars blanket yeah and a night
of is just like right i mean the easiest
way to describe it is it's cereal the
podcast but a fictional version of that
story so it's basically and james
gandolfini was supposed to play the lead
it was going to be his next project
before he died then it just SAT there
they asked John to tour to do it is like
noah james got Finian him were great
friends exact i can't do that that was
his gig it's too weird then he starts
getting you know getting into it he's
like maybe i do this for him and I love
John Turturro that I've loved him since
the day I saw him in every Spike Lee
film he crushes it and do the right
thing he absolutely crushes it in jungle
fever the candy store owner he is
amazing he directed a film right around
that era and I forget the name all the
time can you look this up it was one he
directed he and it was about him and his
two brothers they own their dad's
construction company and it is [ __ ]
great and it
didn't get much glory but if you can see
this movie it is unbelievable and I've
always loved him what was the other one
the Jewish mob once upon a time in
america he the guy murders it every time
the money director was called Mac that's
it Mac and they own a construction
company and it's basically he's got the
loser brother that doesn't do any kind
of work and oh man it's the guy's great
so how is he in this and fantastic it
it's it's fantastic oh and how many
episodes is it it's a limited series and
its eight and I thought there were only
six hour have seven come out is it so
yeah this week was equal 7 um so I don't
know how to take it home and is it on
HBO it's on AJ oh ok yeah i watched
yesterday cuz i wanted to see marin on
roadies yeah so i haven't seen it at all
ron white son i love runway yep Marin
and so and I love [ __ ] the director
of the Creator [ __ ] cameron crowe
chairman Koz cameron crowe's yeah so I
was pretty far enough I don't you know I
it's hard for me to start stuff now
because I really just it's hard for me
to watch TV haha you know like I love
breaking bad but when I got into it I
had the flu for three days and watch
them all and it was the darkest month of
my life I my brain just doesn't take TV
anymore it's and I really want you you
still do films like I did yeah that's
different it's like to our I go I saw a
great [ __ ] film last week the one
about the improv troupe oh yeah yeah my
Biglia don't think the lighting clay yes
film is [ __ ] great man what a great
surprise and a film and just just smokin
man best movie I seeing this year I
loved it anyway I love going to the
movies on Tuesdays over there sunset 5
like today it's six bucks after I do the
podcast I'll roll over catch a movie and
then go do my spots and this movie is
great there's something about TV where I
know it's going to be a lot of episodes
and I think in my mind [ __ ] man
I'm already I gotta I gotta work on some
comedy I gotta edit this podcast I do
need to watch it though because i get i
really like it once i get in right so
but i'm afraid of which one to start
what if it's not good I had to say I
mean there's so much content out there
is a lot of good content just thinking
like I haven't started the get down
there's another show that I hadn't
watched a season two of blood line which
I really love season one of blood line
on netflix I'm not up to date on Game of
Thrones jenos blasphemy just never seen
Game of Thrones ever just like there's
so much and that's not even to say like
what good stuff is maybe on network TV
like far and it gets FX isn't networks
are go or goes incredible yeah the
Americans I think also on FX is
incredible how about Silicon Valley yeah
I love Marin show I love birds f is for
family that stuff so when my friends are
on stuff i watch it right away because I
don't want to be that guy that you know
like I want to support what they're
doing so I watched roadies and it's it's
the six-episode so I have no idea what's
going on but it's a great episode
because Marin is hoping him for a band
and I just done that yeah I was like I
gotta watch you know and its really
funny but that the show is just like you
know it's it's it's like he's [ __ ]
that roadie and this road he's [ __ ]
that roadie and this road is [ __ ]
that one and the band's all [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and you know how I was like oh
yeah I don't need to see this because
I've lived it I'm glad I watched the
Marin episode but I'm gonna watch
something like John Titor to me as an
artist yeah and he moves me from what he
does you know like big time so that's
gonna be my choice yeah now what is
stranger things about cuz i asked Luke
Luke Earl and I don't even think Luke
seen it cuz he were like oh yeah you
know it's 180 stuff dude yeah it is a
what's a logline a paranormal it's a
horror story oh that
in the vein a paranormal horror suspense
story sent in like meets Goonies yeah
old way that's what he said it was like
Goonies ition now is that God I need to
see the darker and skit like legit
scared yeah it's not it's not uh you
know grotesque right but it's a it's a
group of kids without spoiling anything
a group of kids stumble upon a
supernatural being is that vague enough
and he was like hey it's like you want
to stay there's a couple of really great
surprises right if you're into it yeah
that's not really my thing like John
tottori this is like a murder that he
they think he did rod no he's the
attorney oh he's the attorney but
there's somebody that's right i saw him
he's interviewing a guy in itself yeah
and yeah so I like that kind of [ __ ]
where you're falling out imagine I'm
into dark step that's weird right okay
explain that that sounds like something
i want to see ya it's it's great it's
great [ __ ] alright so and then i want to
see the get down I'll watch a couple of
those you know just see what yeah well I
like to look at the era you know cuz i
heard they just nailing it on the air
yeah i'm curious to see how for the same
reason i'm dying up here which is like
Carrie produced show because I saw some
set pics of that and that's very much
capturing the air also and i love that
air like the 70s but now you're also
talking the comedy store and stand up
seeing in that yeah super [ __ ] cool
can't even wait now I've got an offer to
go down and watch him shoot you know and
I'm wondering like should i do that will
the record for me should I as you can
totally do it and then just walk through
camera and no one will notice that could
you'll just fit right a great bring him
back for it let's do that again dear
yeah yeah hang out of the mustache what
is he a new guy
yeah he's their comic comes in midst
midseason oak he's kinnison's friends
whoa I want to play Kinnison leads dice
just a combo character put them both
together like sucking my dick oh right
every wild good night I mean not do it
but a character that's just a moose
[ __ ] cannon around there I think it
as much as I want to be a crazy man in
this era of it's all about business in
this era comedy you can't really be a
crazy man anymore you know so did be
able to play one would be great the
closest crazy man I think we still have
his Katt Williams yeah yeah you're right
but he was fate he got famous and then
good condition I'm talking right now if
you were just doing [ __ ] like huffing
lines and throwing glasses shot glasses
and [ __ ] screaming and kicking people
it's you'd be just gone so I mean this
gun podcasts are always tough so Brandon
please no I mean this with the utmost
respect Brandon Waddell is a young guy
yeah and he's not screaming and kicking
glasses but he uh is crazy on Twitter he
you know for a time he said he wants to
be Drake when he grows up yeah and he's
he's such an original unique voice and
who is a bad boy like how he presents
himself how he acts on stage but not
like bad ways gonna kill someone but
just like giving no [ __ ] but looks like
a skinny white dude but it will be like
in an Adidas jumper with the backpack
yeah like looks like hasn't combed his
hair in 10 days he he was on and Kirk
split album that came out his last album
that came out he had Brandon do like 10
minutes up top at the live show on her
coordinate and he put it in the album
and released it wow so that's a guy I
feel like the bad boy of comedy is
different than like you know sticking a
hookers head through a [ __ ] TV and in
throwing him out the window or whatever
he's a guy who is very much you know
doing his own thing yeah and outside of
like the traditional how you think you
need to handle yourself and stand up to
make it and he's making it he's really
great haven't checked them out check
them out it's a it's it's a toughie it's
a fine line to write because my
most comedians were loony you know and
and eventually I think those guys kind
of had it made back then cuz they could
really vent and go crazy and people I
guess he's crazy as a comedian and they
could get it out yes you know it bottles
up and then you might have a meltdown
one day like we've seen over the years
you know online people have meltdowns
yeah guys having a bad day you know and
yeah because it's a [ __ ] it's a tough
[ __ ] businessman and every day you
wake up you're like really yeah honey
it's always like really so yeah it's 88
it's a strange a strange animal you know
yeah and everything's captured now in a
way that I was at before back then you
Sam Kenneth's can just be a wild man and
then people it was word of mouth yeah
yeah you did this net no he didn't need
it just not here now it's like he did
this okay it's also you blazing yeah
yeah and there's like 10 think pieces
about why it wasn't a good thing pretty
wild I uh I was tweeting today about I
noticed I smell nice okay which isn't
wild and I was like I you know that term
metro mail that's kind of gone now right
yeah you don't really hear a metrosexual
you don't hear but you know i was at
whole foods yeah and I'm like I go to
Whole Foods now cuz they tried by like
clean just clean food Whole Foods Trader
Joe's a bad boy comedy yeah right i'm
really [ __ ] i'm crazy that's a nice
thinking huh i'm gonna send me a couple
days ago man i am so like I think about
good days like I didn't even shower
before at all yeah let's just sit like
I'm wearing the same cuz right now but I
shower so I can get away with it right
you know what's so I'm walking through
all foods ago man that smells good it is
that I look and it's this soap rad soap
company and I I grab it like a man it
smells of me I'm in a smell I hate bad
smells like [ __ ] butthole smell like
people's dirty seats and all that I
smell I go this amazing i buy it it's
seven dollars for a bar
it's huge okay and I and I used the soap
in the shower and it's all natural and
killing I oh god I immediately tweet out
of my dude your [ __ ] is amazed and now
I'm hooked on the stuff and I just I'm
constantly can smell it man smell my arm
it's insane smeller that smells good it
smells good i'm not gonna lie getting
set up for an elaborate hoax here no
yeah isn't it yes okay but my point is
I'm uh somewhere along the line I became
like like a a metrosexual years back I
mean not too crazy like I don't get my
[ __ ] chest waxed my eyebrows and all
that [ __ ] done but i'm into good smells
it's crazy well i think i think there
should be more of it and i think the
label I think we don't call it
metrosexual or whatever because that the
two reasons one like the fashion
stereotype move to hipster or whatever
like whatever the thing is like there's
a term for the thing but to I think like
just like a woman can be President or a
boss or an astronaut or fight in the
military a man can get a manicure or
pedicure oh god what was his name [ __ ]
blanking on his name very famous black
comedian was in the oceans 11 movies
he's dead unfortunately come on brain
why did I start this [ __ ] train of
thought Bernie Mac Bernie Mac thank you
bring that Christ he was huge on
mani-pedis yeah like and he was you know
like a tough dude funny dude wild guy
and he would always like you gotta have
nice nails yeah like guys are all want
like a good firm handshake he's like I'm
not gonna shake your hand if your nails
look like [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
don't I haven't but I want to get my
eyebrows not like shaped like to look
again like I'm a hairy dude I think like
adding like a real if you watch TV all
of those people on TV have had that [ __ ]
done oh god you have like big upon them
and you're like no wonder when you get
up in the morning you take a shower and
you style your hair like not talking
about how attractive you are at a base
level you're like this doesn't look like
how I want it does a course it doesn't
there you see on TV isn't that yeah so I
think the only thing I would do that I
haven't done in terms of like male
grooming is going like going like a dude
eyebrow oh yeah yeah get that [ __ ]
cleaned up a little bit but barbershops
do it go good on you know
mean I got a one in [ __ ] he gets it
he gets down on the [ __ ] eyebrows and
stuff it's crazy because you know like I
think a lot of twitter is shame in
people's like bad hair or smells of
clothing sure yeah I mean it's like oh
like people got that Yoda ear hair
coming out and uh and other people have
like you know Nikolai guy can get some
[ __ ] yeah like I get furry on the
neck yeah it's it's crazy like how I
feel good when I go to the barber shop
and they cut everything off yeah I might
just get rid of everything yeah and they
just feel like all right I'm clean yeah
I mean I think there is something to do
we have a call yeah we got a care of
themselves y'all get back yeah yeah yeah
let's go let's grab the call hey what's
up you're on the air man who's calling
what's up you sit sit bastard this is
the Ginen she Boston right on how are
you man not so what's going on you guys
we're just here talking about all kinds
of [ __ ] are you listening in to the show
I'm not just an awful luck where'd you
got a question today that's not always
just wanted to call in I have a question
for you then I'm gonna put you on the
spot you don't have to answer it yet you
can think about it for a little bit but
before you go you got to answer it
favorite movie set in Boston there's a
lot a lot of great Boston movies I want
to know from a Boston Boston guy I don't
know what you guys are called boss
tonight but Dhoni exhausted oh yeah
heard about that what's your favorite
Boston moves oh my favorite Boston will
leave town okay town it's a good movie I
like the one with the UH what's his name
was Ben Affleck and Mark Wahlberg it's
either Mark Wahlberg water no Leo what's
it called departed depart oh yeah which
is also mark wahlberg yeah yeah olive oh
no what's the fighters great that's
Boston right yeah the freighter well
that's like an hour and oil yeah yeah
that [ __ ] is great now I love the babe
casey affleck Gone Baby Gone
unbelievable too yeah yeah oh yeah
you're right that's a great like Boston
like New York has some great movies
but Boston has some [ __ ] great movie
I was in Boston it was amazing and the
guy goes yeah let's go get some food and
we went to the north end and it was
unbelievable bound to a gorilla that
[ __ ] is cure yeah on the in August every
weekend saw the fishermen fest so they
decide so like sweet food old like all
this fresh seafood right off the boat in
town so damn that's our Molly clams
oysters everywhere it's unbelievable
well I'll be right back i'm gonna meet
you there yeah young man goes go see a
mirror and he's doing the Wilbur woohoo
Marc Maron he's doing the wilbur theatre
oh yes I go so many shows and [ __ ] I'll
have running oh I might have seen a
local though at the robot November
whatever the hell is this oh that's
gonna be my third time seeing him that's
gonna be dope tiered oh yeah it's nice
at all I'm like all right fourth time
simply 22 definitely the worst time for
Arctic it's the worst time I don't know
I glow the police say was that always
great sound sounds awful hmm that's
better the total been away well yeah all
right well it'll be a no I'm seeing him
in LA for the last couple show so I'm
hopeful that yeah oh oh well then now
yeah thanks for calling in good talk you
guys right all right oh man see ya later
but that's want to go to Boston and eat
now that guy was so Boston yeah great if
I wanted nose favorite Boston it sound
like Devon my my boiler poison whites
Nick oh yeah yeah everything's hot dude
no oh you gotta go down there blink-182
terrible I can't even do it it's so hard
yes Omega do it looks like da field
Kenny I can hit the hit the long a or
whatever yeah it's I am it's like you
know I could probably do it if I just
listened to it for about a week yeah
I'll probably kill it but it's so weird
when it comes on your like anybody
thinks we just sound like Spicoli yeah
anyway we're talking about factory and
grooming yeah I mean I think we've got
to a point now where it's like you know
we have the time to do it we're not
working you know 12 hour days in a coal
mine than coming home and slamming food
and then getting up the next day and
doing again so it's like take care of
yourself yeah I don't think you need to
smell like a pretty pretty flower but
you don't need to smell like you just
played [ __ ] football no one's gonna
be like all that guy's not tough you
doesn't smell like [ __ ] don't smell like
[ __ ] you don't need to do that anymore
well you know it I love the total you
know like to me I fantasize it's a lot
like anything in life I love either one
way all the way or the other way sure so
of course you know i love more Jim
Morrison and just wore the same clothes
his entire tour and people just said he
smelled so bad but there's something I
always I it's so funny I always look at
stemming um yeah these are gonna look
great when it's all broken yeah and I
never get them broken because the other
half of my brain is going I gotta keep
these mints man I got to keep them all
clean in case I gotta sell them you know
that's why i am with like hats and shoes
were all like I get a when I I've since
broken the addiction for sneakers but I
get like a great pair of Jordans or
something like that and I beg all these
are awesome i'm never gonna wig away
these for special occasions that I'd
have liked my [ __ ] pair yeah but then by
the end of like a year or whatever my
ship pair would be my favorite pair
because I had memories with them yeah
they went through some [ __ ] so even if
it was something where I would wear like
the nice ones i would pick to where the
[ __ ] ones it seemed was like hats or
it'd be like i could never wear this
once limited edition it was only
available at a minute maid park when the
astros were on the world series on
forever next to the ticket stubs wear to
the opening day game that's it I never
wear that [ __ ] hat I know and I wear
like my beater all the time it's so
[ __ ] weird man right like and I also
was talking to somebody about how boots
look amazing beat up and broke in but
sneakers look like [ __ ] beat up an old
do to me yeah yeah so it's so weird
sneakers just have this shelf life of
about am I
they're like that these don't look too
good yeah and also you're bored with
sneakers quick no well with the boots
you never get bored of me like these are
looking great I start now I can't wait
to get them resoled man they're gonna be
[ __ ] great so yeah it's a it's so
weird I still I still fantasize about
the [ __ ] one outfit yeah yeah yeah my
like when I did hell ride I had a giant
beard and I grew my hair out cuz I knew
like four months ahead of time just
gonna do it then they go yeah so you go
come in to make up every morning around
4 30 and we'll put this beard and wig on
yeah I was like oh I want to avoid that
I can just start growing this [ __ ] now
so I grew a beard out for months ahead
he saw pictures of it was massive and I
kind of liked the beard I would have a
giant one now but it's straight up gray
oh yeah I look nice Santa you could die
it I look like Santa's uncle grandfather
that's how ya Diana to there you go you
know and it's like Browns and then brush
it in yeah yeah yeah the carriers when
is it call that not just for justice man
oh my god what's the other illusion and
this is you know we live in Hollywood
but I do you think it's weird and I'm at
the point now where and I might do it
I'm not saying I'm above doing it but if
I ever want to start dyeing my hair yeah
I'm kind of I need to start now like I
don't have tons of Gray's yeah there's a
few yeah and so if I never want to the
people to notice like I kind of need to
do it and you look at celebrities and
there's you know first of all there's
John Travolta just we're straight-up
[ __ ] wigs on I don't want legs no
clue he looks like any more like George
Clooney went grey but he sells a
gorgeous [ __ ] full head of hair like
there's no way well his gray looks cool
cuz you right we got a call and I
grabbed him it's a hair looks cool Yeah
right but it's not real I don't think
it's real hmm what's going on man you're
on the air
what's up teens el rey and miss hider
how we got how we doing today yeah good
who's calling Oh Nate out of Santa Rosa
for the cough you guys a shout Nate out
of [ __ ] rose up with part of santa
rosa you live in all right at julia park
next to what Juilliard park kind of done
pal oh right on right on yeah it's nice
man hey I actually saw Bryan Callen at
the punch line on Friday oh wow well you
didn't murder her yeah yeah my lawyer
went to that he said is [ __ ] great I
come down to Mountain I got hair it
looks like a mountain lion or a lion's
mane I've got a horse and it's I just
got muscles and I got muscles on top of
the horse yeah just like first time i
ever saw was like this guy's amazing
yeah and it's cesar my murderer it's so
hilarious you know mega like africa that
[ __ ] is like it takes balls to do that
because for a long time how do you work
that out at open mics you know what i
mean because when we start we're doing
classic joke we're doing jokes at an
open mic so an open mic that means he
has to go in there when starting and be
like I'm Callan I got a six pack my hair
looks perfect people blood [ __ ] this guy
you know to me so I love him even more
how to develop that man that is just
next level and every time I [ __ ]
laugh when he's on every time the way he
deconstructed the contact he was talking
about it he's just so cool because he
call ER he won the room no you're even
got up there because the fighter in the
kid and it was a phenomenal man it was
so clean yeah a nice guy now is he's on
tour with the fighter and the kid is the
other guy on stage with him Brendan
Schaub it depends on the show when they
do live shows they end up they know it's
come or what the performance right like
you know you know how some talk shows
are but apparently Brendan Schaub he's
now doing stand
he doesn't call self atomic his words
but he's getting into it now and they
they talk about UFC MMA jiu jitsu
hammering food you know online I love
that [ __ ] didn't love it that guy the
first time I saw him was at the comedy
store I'll sit in the back and I'd never
seen him and it was early on in my
comedy career and he went on and I was
like what what the [ __ ] this is insane i
love it i mean i was worship in it and
the best thing about colin is that he
was your age about you guys still act so
it's relatable immediately because it's
not I'm an old man blah blah blah so on
so forth it's just really relatable
content yeah yes that's the thing I
think that you can like other people you
got electrocuted okay a lot of people
understand like you can be old and
comedy as long as you're relevant here
to me if you're not up there talking
about like you know like going you know
wearing a blazer and talking about you
know whatever pac-man accepted from the
aliens people are gonna be like this guy
is [ __ ] out of touch you know but if
you're up there just talking creators it
doesn't matter what age you are if your
material is relevant well what you're
doing now it's really it's really quite
different than when I first saw you in
Denver is really evolved just bring a
lot of like a critical thinking and it's
so funny and really engaging but thanks
to you for coming all right I have to be
out there soon I really hope so the
punchline man it's gentrification has
really it's really enhance a lot of
things but comedy sets like a wind up
going to the place Louis's in San
Francisco Brian down and a bunch of
chuckle flux right that's fun i'm sure
that but then no idea who he was and pan
is hot
his career and our family and then
they're all I trying to fit on like oh
you guys are Thanks with support for you
can apply the problem well I think it's
I think it's a great place to be in the
crew if you're big from your podcasting
South the rooms but still be able to
walk the streets man what what better
whoa you just got your real your real
friends in that on the show thanks for
text thanks for calling in did yeah my
man deeply I'll see you soon Matt right
seem like a real nice guy but why the
[ __ ] did he started by dissing me yeah
What did he say to you it was like
what's up Dean and miss spice or
whatever the [ __ ] he said I'd I said
Chris Speier did he say Chris I heard a
myth we're gonna go back listen to the
tape if it was Chris thanks that's not
my name but that's better others like a
Miss i saw a silent the whole time it's
like [ __ ] this dude like he's calls like
hey i just want to call and give you
guys a shout locker Dean with a [ __ ]
face [ __ ] boy anyway for the I'm a big
fan I was like [ __ ] this guy alright
let's keep this guy on what's up coach
and he really likes my material i got
that was one of my nine fans by yeah
yeah oh it's by the way man I've been
screaming at people to leave reviews and
subscribe to the podcast huh like every
week it blows my mind you know this
podcast has massive numbers yeah massive
and it has only 633 reviewers it makes
no sense to me how you gonna have all
these listen so anyway in the last week
I've gotten like 9 reviews nice [ __ ]
yeah keep it going man that's how it
gets in the top 50 well that's that's a
thing and I understand because people
myself included we are lazy and we take
things for granted that that's the
beauty of an RSS feed for a podcast you
subscribe to it then it shows up on your
phone and then you're driving like oh
[ __ ] there's a new let there be talked
I'll listen to that ya like hey
subscribe and you're like yeah I'll do
that but you're driving so you're not
going to do it and then you get home and
you got your wife or your kids or your
partner or whatever and you're cooking
dinner you're not going to work in it or
not and it's just like I listen to NPR a
lot and it took me years before I
finally became a sustaining
like I've always liked I want to support
this yeah but you never do it so it's
frustrating to me too because I get it
like my this show and the video game
podcast I do I was just when I release
my album it was like look if ten percent
of you time by my album and I don't even
care if you'd buy it because you like me
like my comedy just think of it as like
a ten dollar tip too hey thanks for the
hundreds of hours of free content yeah
people like yeah and I get amazing is
frustrating as seriously I'll do it guys
the reason Dean wants you to subscribe
and leave a review on your provider of
choice for this podcast is because it
helps in discoverability and by getting
it more reviews more you have to write
anything you know to write actual
comments on iTunes it's a five star
review it bumps it in the iTunes
algorithm so when other people are
looking for dope podcasts this podcast
will be surfaced in this podcast is not
like Metallica and 72 or whatever it
isn't like you don't want people to know
about it because it won't be cool
anymore if more people know about this
[ __ ] pocket enter guess it gets
better and better and all those people
that you want to do to be on the show
will be able to be on the show and also
Dean will have a gold jet yeah yeah joe
gold yeah what I was thinking I was like
how can I make it to where you can't
listen unless you subscribe and leave a
review well I think that it's free you
can't listen unless you subscribe do you
know what I mean I wonder if there is a
model cuz there is that oh god what is
it's like not gorilla but there's that
other there like a new kind of podcast
service that you have to pay to get the
money it's like a block or something I
don't want him to pay I mean of course
it would be great yeah to donate or
whatever I've been doing this so long
for free but eventually you're like man
you know if you just subscribed it would
keep it up in the top 50 and then the
guest ark would be way but I'm starting
to get great get in the next few weeks
the guests are [ __ ] through them I'm
here yeah I got Spicer I got crisp I see
Miss Spicer yeah but you know what I
mean it's like what happens is
publicists start reaching out to you and
this just
happened to me last three weeks ago
publicist hit me and said here's who I
represent do you like any of them
because I don't have people on that I
don't I don't care about I'm not a
promotion machine and immediately I saw
rich robinson I said [ __ ] yeah yeah
right there rich robinson down the black
cross now that was because the show the
publicist had heard this might be good
for your client right and she had two
other clients Vicki Hamilton which was a
guest I've been wanting for two years
and at her on you know who managed guns
and roses at the beginning to great
guests that's from [ __ ] you know the
podcast is circling around out there and
getting some yeah getting some traction
yeah this month I just tweeted today the
biggest month ever of left to be talkin
I downloads that's awesome yeah that is
[ __ ] and like I'm waking up now going
like whoa these numbers are crazy yeah
oh and that's just you got to just keep
working and doing it you know yeah and
one great thing I do like about the show
is the the numbers seem to be around the
same as if I do it with just you or me
on my own yeah yeah or superstar guest
sure now I know the show's interesting
and and and people are digging it it's
not dependent on a big name it's kind of
like stand-up shows in town like the
meltdown or whatever it be people just
yet it's you know it's gonna be a great
show even if it's something that you're
not necessarily into per se like I don't
give a [ __ ] about custom engraved shift
knobs for 64 Mustangs only yeah it's
gonna be an interesting listen so I'm
gonna check it out yeah it's uh it's
funny it's funny like this week I'm
gonna interview this guy who restores
Rolexes okay this one's for me yeah like
if people but I went to his shop
yesterday and watched him do some work
and I was like I can't [ __ ] believe
he's like 40 white dude I walk in he
goes Oh Dean Del Rey I go you know me is
like odesk wad man I go to the I go to
that [ __ ] ice house man
I saw your great i love Joey Diaz and I
was like wow this is so cool from
podcast down I immediately said did you
got to do my podcast he goes oh I'd be
honored he starts showing me all the
stuff he does is the vintage Rolexes and
I'm an interview Saturday an awesome
[ __ ] it fired up yeah this guy's he's in
pasadena is just insane man that's
awesome yes bring old Rolex with you
yeah yeah anyway why you just walk me as
hypothetically just walk me through the
process you need this one right here
yeah this is cool for a podcast [ __ ]
that's all they work where do you got
going man this week we're doing a show
together oh yeah yeah thursdays at
thursday thursday 8pm no tickets sold so
far unbelievable has her a link for it
yeah yeah i haven't seen in it tweeted
it like two days straight uh uh let's
see yeah it's me you uh Joe Bartnik and
red band okay and an ally okay so yeah I
tweeted up you know what I don't think
you're in the first cuz i only got room
to put it one each time I uh I gotta
start using that thing again remember
where it shrunk the link oh sure well
now I think Twitter automatically does
that I think if it wants it determines
its a link it doesn't count it as its
full carat really yeah oh wow because
how do you do that there's just when you
type a link in so if you know whatever
as you once you add like calm to the end
of it Twitter's like oh this is a link
and the think'll link takes eight
character I don't know what it look into
other things anyway so yeah thursday we
got to get come out so here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to try to run some
of this new stuff on thursday i got
about you know 15 minutes of new stuff
that i'm trying to get [ __ ] primo and
then i'm going to do some really new
stuff like all my notes and see what I
get going then you guys do whatever you
want to do bark Nick redban you Hallie
and then trying to get a surprise guest
nice yeah so that should be girls day 8
p.m. at the compass around the belly
room here is Angeles which would be
tonight when this comes out okay tonight
come out tonight yeah quit take your
earbuds out I think it's actually 730
okay I don't know
I don't know cuz you haven't yeah don't
hasn't told me about it i'll pay it
together anyway so that's thursday and
then friday i'm going to be at our
saturday i mean i'm doing malibu play
house again oh cool love this place
young what a great the whole all in
malibu comes out there man I'll cool
it's like people that never leave Malibu
and why would you why would you yeah
right and I love doing comedy out there
pushing buttons yeah yeah and so I'm
doing that on Saturday and then I'm at
the store on Sunday I'm doing juice this
week nice Wow huh so yeah I got some
good shows coming up and then Monday on
let to be talk is going to be barren
woman the first photographer for a
rolling stone magazine yeah I saw some
of those [ __ ] pictures incredible god
damn II shut Rowling's a shot at
Woodstock yeah on stage he prayed
cowbell with Santana him and Bill Graham
up there his photo he he was smart
instead of shooting I think I said this
before instead of shooting bands like
everybody's doing he shot the people the
cars the mud they track the gear the
[ __ ] stage the fences that got pushed
down it felt like you were there yeah
he's got a photo where he's on stage and
he shot out words 300,000 people it's
crazy how do possess three hundred
thousands of our mom's dad I think time
machine time machine if you could pick
one event what would it be man I was
looking at that like time machine you
get to get one [ __ ] thing man i was
like it would probably Woodstock for me
yeah I mean I depends how quickly can
get out of there like being there when
Jesus kind of rises again would kind of
be [ __ ] mind-blowing because you'd be
like hey that is real [ __ ] my life I'm
going to help
it would be pretty phenomenal a machine
you get to get a one [ __ ] place yeah
one that's a tough that's a tough
question to drop at the end of a [ __ ]
uh I know the end of a [ __ ] episode
Woodstock is an easy answer but you've
planted that seed already so that's why
it's it's kind of stuck in my head uh
from her firm hemming and hawing up
hitting hi I mean do you go back and
watch the [ __ ] you know the first
Apollo you know take off to our you're
an astronaut yeah you know I don't know
what are the rules of it you get to go
in the time machine and you could be a
president a dare I don't know Jesse
Owens winning 100 years old man that's
killer the olympics in berlin that's
running thing you really that would be
[ __ ] i mean it also surrounded by
nazis though well but i'm in a time
machine but nothing it and then the
Nazis get the time machine oh no I [ __ ]
it up yeah yeah I ok so let's see let's
leave this for the Twitter people a
tweet at us over the weekend you don't
get to be the person but you get the
time machine and you get to go to one
event experience it yep you get to go to
the event like whatever it was Kennedy
assassination [ __ ] Woodstock Ollie
rumble in the jungle I you know Evel
Knievel jump in those truck The
Fountains at Caesar's Palace yeah these
are some of my career of Star Wars
Episode one of phantom menace no no one
should pick them yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah Karen you know what i mean so sweet
what yours would be and let's have a
good weekend and candles lit and oh one
last thing i'll be in arizona next
weekend at the house of comedy all labor
day weekend so come out Arizona House a
comedy and you got any shows I don't
know I just know thursday i'm living a
week at a time man i'm running ragged if
you like video games though video game
podcast i do is called dlc and you
mentioned Rolling Stone they have spun
out a video game part called Glick cyl
which is like that same kind of rolling
stone flavor yeah you know and love
talking about video games and tech it's
pretty cool Wow yeah i'm going to talk
quite a bit about rolling stone magazine
monday before band comes on thanks for
turning guys leave those reviews candles
leaked